Hallo, mein Name ist Olivia Lanes, und willkommen zurück bei Quantum Computing in der Praxis. Das ist Episode zwei: Quantum
circuits. Wir werden in der heutigen Lektion mehrere Themen behandeln, aber ich möchte, dass du drei Dinge mitnimmst. Erstens: Was IBM-
Quantencomputer tatsächlich sind, damit du zumindest ein grobes Bild davon hast, was du machst, wenn du einen Job über die
Cloud an einen dieser Computer schickst. Zweitens: Was ein qubit ist, was Primitives sind und wie wir sie verwenden können, um Quantum circuits zu erstellen und auszuführen.
Wir werden auch auf hohem Niveau die verschiedenen Arten von IBM-Quantenprozessoren besprechen, die verfügbar sind, und was einen vom anderen unterscheidet. Und drittens:
Schließlich der typische Workflow, den wir befolgen, um Experimente in großem Maßstab durchzuführen. Dazu gehört die Auswahl der besten Primitives
für deinen Anwendungsfall, die Abbildung eines Problems auf einen Quantum circuit und die Anwendung von Fehlerunterdrückung und -minderung, die es uns ermöglichen,
so viel Leistung wie möglich aus diesen Maschinen herauszuholen. Es gibt hier zwar viele Informationen, aber bleib bei mir,
denn schon bald werden wir alles im Kontext einiger echter Beispiele zusammenfügen. Zunächst wollen wir kurz qubits und die eigentliche Quantum-
Hardware besprechen. Als Experimentalwissenschaftlerin kann ich dir versprechen, dass es faszinierend ist und es wirklich hilft, die Zusammenhänge zu verstehen,
wenn man sich vorstellt, was tatsächlich passiert, wenn Jobs über die Cloud an einen Quantencomputer gesendet werden. Die Prozessoren,
die wir verwenden werden, sind mit supraleitenden Transmon-qubits aufgebaut. So sieht ein kleiner IBM-Quantenprozessor aus.
Diese kleinen Quadrate hier sind die qubits selbst, es gibt also insgesamt fünf auf diesem Chip. Das Transmon
selbst ist ein Kondensator und besteht aus zwei Metallplatten, die parallel mit einem nichtlinearen Induktor, dem sogenannten
Josephson-Kontakt, verbunden sind. Um den Josephson-Kontakt zu sehen, muss man jedoch noch weiter hineinzoomen. Er wird aus zwei
überlappenden Schichten aus supraleitendem Metall hergestellt, und wo die beiden Stücke sich überlappen und berühren, befindet sich der Kontakt. Ein Josephson-
Kontakt ist ein Element, das verwendet werden kann, um ein künstliches Atom mit mehreren Energieniveaus zu erzeugen, und wir isolieren
die untersten beiden Energieniveaus als unseren qubit-Zustand. Die geschwungenen Linien hier stellen die Mikrowellenresonatoren dar,
im Wesentlichen 2D-Übertragungsleitungen, die mit dem qubit gekoppelt sind. Wenn wir jetzt einen gate programmieren, entspricht das im Wesentlichen der Auswahl eines
hochkalibrierten Mikrowellenpulses, und die spezifische Frequenz, Amplitude, Form und Dauer dieser Pulse bewirken, dass das
qubit bestimmte Dinge tut. Die Anweisungen für den Mikrowellenpuls gehen von deinem Computer in die Cloud und
werden dann von der Steuerelektronik bei Raumtemperatur gelesen und interpretiert, die diese Anweisungen aufnimmt und physisch
die Pulse erzeugt. Wir nennen sie Mikrowellenpulse, weil sie alle in den Mikrowellenfrequenzbereich passen,
der bei etwa 1 GHz liegt. Nachdem die Steuerboxen bei Raumtemperatur die Pulse erzeugt haben, laufen sie durch die Kabel
in den Verdünnungskühlschrank und schließlich zu unserem Quantenchip. Das Signal geht über einen
Drahtbond auf diesen Pads in die Resonatoren und fließt dann die Übertragungsleitung hinunter zu unseren qubits. Ich weiß, das alles wirkt
vielleicht etwas technisch, und diese Details sind für uns im weiteren Verlauf nicht entscheidend zu verstehen, aber ich hoffe, dass du jetzt
zumindest das physische System vor Augen hast, mit dem du gleich interagieren wirst. Wo befinden sich diese Quantencomputer also
tatsächlich? Nun, IBM hat Dutzende von Quantencomputern auf der ganzen Welt, und wir haben kürzlich unsere Flotte aufgerüstet, sodass sie
nur noch Prozessoren mit 100 oder mehr qubits enthält. Wie ich in der vorherigen Lektion erwähnt habe, befinden sich einige davon in einem IBM
Quantum-Rechenzentrum im Bundesstaat New York. Diese Systeme sind über die Cloud für alle zugänglich, und einige
davon sind dedizierte On-Premise-Systeme, komplett mit der gesamten Elektronik, die sie zum Funktionieren benötigen, und die unsere Partner
im IBM Quantum-Netzwerk unterstützen. Sprechen wir nun über Qiskit, IBMs Open-Source-Software-Entwicklungskit,
das für die Arbeit mit Quantencomputern entwickelt wurde. Von nun an werde ich dieses als das Qiskit SDK bezeichnen. Es gibt auch das Qiskit-
Ökosystem, eine Sammlung von Software, Tutorials und Funktionen, die auf den Kernfunktionalitäten von Qiskit aufbauen oder diese erweitern, sowie Qiskit
Runtime, einen Quantum-Computing-Dienst und ein Programmiermodell, das es Nutzern ermöglicht, ihre Quantum-Workloads zu entwerfen und effizient
auszuführen, indem sie Qiskit Primitives verwenden. Ein Primitive ist im Grunde ein kleiner Baustein, den
du verwenden kannst, um größere circuits oder einen Job zu entwerfen. Die zwei Primitives, die für uns am wichtigsten sind, werden der
Sampler und der Estimator sein, auf die wir gleich näher eingehen werden. Falls du das
Qiskit SDK noch nicht heruntergeladen und installiert hast, ist jetzt der richtige Zeitpunkt. Qiskit 1.0 wurde kürzlich veröffentlicht und ist leistungsfähiger und
stabiler als je zuvor. Für diejenigen, die gerade erst anfangen: Ihr seid zum perfekten Zeitpunkt eingestiegen. Für diejenigen,
die bereits mit Qiskit vertraut sind: Ihr müsst die neueste Version herunterladen und neu installieren. Wir empfehlen,
pip zu verwenden, um Qiskit und Qiskit Runtime zu installieren, und sie über ein Jupyter-Notebook in einem Webbrowser deiner Wahl auszuführen. Du wirst also auch
Jupyter Notebook oder JupyterLab installieren müssen, falls du das noch nicht getan hast. Diese Tools sind alle kostenlos, und du
kannst sie auf deiner eigenen lokalen Maschine ohne Kosten zum Laufen bringen. Stelle sicher, dass du Qiskit mit den Visualisierungs-
Abhängigkeiten hinzufügst, damit es mit Jupyter funktioniert und du Dinge plotten kannst. Du musst auch eine virtuelle Python-Umgebung einrichten, und es gibt
Anweisungen dazu auf der Qiskit-Installationsseite, die hier verlinkt ist. Sobald du mit Qiskit vertraut bist und
bereit bist, Jobs auf echten Quantencomputern auszuführen, musst du dich auf quantum.com registrieren und einen IBM Quantum
API-Token erstellen. Dazu gibt es auch einen Link hier. Eine detaillierte Schritt-für-Schritt-Anleitung dazu findest du, wenn du alle
Anweisungen auf unserer Dokumentationsseite befolgst, wie ich erwähnt habe, oder du kannst dir hier das Qiskit-Installationsvideo ansehen,
die beide in der Beschreibung verlinkt sind. Jetzt sind wir fast bereit, über Quantum
circuits zu sprechen. Da es das Ziel dieses Kurses ist, dir als Lernenden beizubringen, wie du deine Jobs auf 100 oder mehr
qubits skalieren kannst, halte ich es für den konstruktivsten Weg, zunächst den gesamten Workflow zu betrachten, dem wir folgen werden. Der einfachste Weg,
einen typischen Quantum-Computing-Workflow zu verstehen, ist über Qiskit-Patterns. Qiskit-Patterns sind ein konzeptionelles Framework, das es Nutzern ermöglicht, Quantum-
Workloads durch die Implementierung bestimmter Schritte mit modularen Werkzeugen auszuführen. Dies ermöglicht es, Quantum-Computing-Aufgaben von einer
leistungsfähigen heterogenen Computing-Infrastruktur zu erledigen. Diese Schritte können als Dienst ausgeführt werden und können
Ressourcenverwaltung beinhalten, was eine nahtlose Zusammensetzbarkeit neuer Fähigkeiten ermöglicht, sobald diese entwickelt werden. Hier
sind die Hauptschritte, die erfahrene Qiskit-Nutzer wahrscheinlich bereits kennen werden. Der erste Schritt ist das Mapping. Dieser Schritt
formalisiert, wie wir ein allgemeines Problem, das uns interessiert, nehmen und herausfinden, wie wir es auf einen Quantencomputer
in Form eines circuit abbilden. Als Nächstes optimieren wir. In diesem Schritt verwenden wir den Qiskit transpiler, um den
circuit auf tatsächliche physische Quantum-Hardware zu routen und anzuordnen. Dazu gehört die Übersetzung der einzelnen Quantum gates in Sequenzen
von Operationen, die auf der Hardware ausgeführt werden, sowie die Optimierung der Anordnung dieser gates. Als Nächstes werden wir
ausführen. Qiskit Runtime Primitives stellen die Schnittstelle zur IBM Quantum Hardware bereit, über die der transpilierte circuit ausgeführt wird.
Dieser Schritt umfasst auch die Verwendung von Fehlerunterdrückungs- und -minderungstechniken, die weitgehend vom Nutzer abstrahiert werden können. Abschließend erfolgt die Nachverarbeitung. In
diesem Schritt werden die Daten des Quantenprozessors selbst verarbeitet und dem Nutzer nützliche Ergebnisse zum ursprünglichen Problem geliefert. Im Wesentlichen umfasst dieser Schritt
jede weitere Analyse der gewonnenen Daten. Jetzt sind wir bereit, die Grundlage von Quanten-
programmen zu besprechen, nämlich Quantum circuits. Hoffentlich bist du bereits mit Quantum circuits vertraut, aber falls nicht, solltest du dir vielleicht zuerst Lektion
drei, Quantum circuits, ansehen, die Teil von "Understanding Quantum Information and Computation" ist und unten verlinkt ist. Wir werden hier nur
eine kurze Wiederholung geben. Ein Quantum circuit ist ein Netzwerk aus Quantum gates und Messungen, die
durch Leitungen verbunden sind, die die qubits darstellen. Quantum circuits können wie Noten von links nach rechts gelesen werden, beginnend bei
Zeitpunkt Null, ganz links. Virtuelle qubits, also qubits, die noch keinem physischen qubit
auf einem Prozessor zugewiesen wurden, sind in aufsteigender Reihenfolge von oben nach unten aufgeführt. Sobald wir unseren circuit eingerichtet haben, können wir
gates hinzufügen. Einzelne qubit-gates wie dieser Hadamard-gate hier beeinflussen nur das qubit, auf dessen Leitung er platziert ist. Mehrere qubit-
gates wie dieser CNOT beeinflussen zwei oder mehr qubits, die durch den gate verbunden sind. In diesem Beispiel ändert sich der Zustand von qubit eins
je nachdem, in welchem Zustand sich qubit null nach dem Anwenden aller gates befindet, können wir Messungen durchführen,
die dazu führen, dass die Ergebnisse in klassische Register geschrieben werden. Eine besonders wichtige Eigenschaft eines
circuit ist seine Tiefe. Die Tiefe des Quantum circuit ist die Mindestanzahl an Schichten von Quantum gates, die parallel ausgeführt werden,
um die durch den circuit definierte Berechnung abzuschließen. Um das klarzustellen: Quantum gates können parallel ausgeführt werden,
also zur exakt gleichen Zeit, sofern sie keine qubits gemeinsam haben. Wenn aber zwei oder mehr
gates auf dieselben qubits wirken, können wir sie nicht parallel ausführen – wir müssen sie nacheinander ausführen, da Quantum gates Zeit benötigen,
um sie zu implementieren. Die Tiefe eines circuit entspricht ungefähr der Zeit, die Quantencomputer für die Ausführung des
circuit benötigen. Daher ist es wichtig, die Tiefe eines circuit zu kennen, um zu wissen, ob er auf einem bestimmten Gerät lauffähig ist oder nicht. Es gibt uns auch einen Hinweis, ob
er eine gute Chance hat, ein genaues Ergebnis zu liefern. Kommen wir nun zur Auswahl eines Quantenprozessors. IBM
hat kürzlich eine ganze neue Flotte von Prozessoren herausgebracht, die alle über 100 qubits verfügen, und du kannst dich bei quantum.com einloggen, um zu sehen,
auf welche Prozessoren du Zugriff hast. Die Prozessoren sind aus bestimmten Gründen alle nach Vögeln benannt, und die verschiedenen Logos
stehen für verschiedene Prozessortypen. Diese hier repräsentieren zum Beispiel Eagle-Prozessoren, und dieses Symbol ist ein
Reiher. Die Namen der einzelnen Prozessoren stehen ebenfalls oben – sie sind alle nach Städten benannt, aber das
bedeutet nicht zwangsläufig, dass der Prozessor auch physisch in dieser Stadt steht. Das sind nur Namen. Die qubit-Anzahl,
EPPG und CLOPS sind weitere Faktoren, die alle aufgelistet sind. Wir werden jeden davon noch durchgehen.
qubits – das ist ziemlich selbsterklärend: qubits ist einfach die Gesamtanzahl der verfügbaren qubits auf diesem einzelnen Quantenprozessor bzw.
QPU. EPPG steht für „errors per layered gate" und misst den durchschnittlichen gate-Prozessfehler in einer geschichteten Kette von
100 qubits – du willst diesen Wert so klein wie möglich halten. CLOPS steht für „circuit layer operations per second" und
misst, wie viele Schichten eines Quantum-Volume-circuit – ein virtueller circuit – eine QPU pro Zeiteinheit ausführen kann.
Je höher die Zahl, desto schneller können wir berechnen. Das entspricht dem, was FLOPS im klassischen Computing bedeutet. Diese
verschiedenen Metriken können je nach dem spezifischen Anwendungsbereich, der dich interessiert, mehr oder weniger wichtig sein. Sprechen wir nun auf einer hohen Ebene über das
Mapping auf Quantum circuits. Der erste Schritt ist der Mapping-Schritt, der im Wesentlichen die Frage beantwortet: Wie
übersetze ich mein Problem in einen Quantum circuit, der auf Quantum-Hardware ausgeführt werden kann? Da besteht kein Zweifel:
Mapping ist ein schwieriges Problem und ein aktives Forschungsgebiet. Manchmal ist allein die Fähigkeit, ein Berechnungs-
problem zu nehmen und eine Folge von Quantum gates zu entwickeln, die bei der Lösung hilft, der schwierigste Teil. Es gibt keine narrensichere
Methode, die Erfolg garantiert, aber es gibt empfohlene Richtlinien und Beispiele für Probleme, die wir bereits wissen, wie wir sie
mappen können. Die erste Richtlinie lautet: Lass klassische Computer die Arbeit erledigen, die sie besser können. Tests,
die für klassische Computer einfach sind, werden wahrscheinlich nicht von einem Quantencomputer profitieren. Quantencomputer sind für Probleme gedacht, die klassisch schwer sind.
Natürlich, wenn du Qiskit oder einen Quantencomputer zum allerersten Mal verwendest – mach dir keine Sorgen darum, ein computationell komplexes Problem zu finden. Zerlege es
in kleinere Probleme, die du lösen lernst, bevor du direkt zu einem Utility-Scale-Projekt übergehst. Übersetze als nächstes die
Ergebnisse deines Problems, die du messen oder verstehen möchtest, in ein Erwartungswert-Problem oder ein Stichproben-
problem. Bei den meisten Problemtypen entspricht das im Wesentlichen der Berechnung einer Kostenfunktion. Eine Kostenfunktion ist eine
problemspezifische Funktion, die das Ziel des Problems als etwas definiert, das minimiert oder maximiert werden soll, und sie können
verwendet werden, um zu sehen, wie gut ein Testzustand oder eine Lösung in Bezug auf dieses Ziel abschneidet.
Dieses Konzept lässt sich auf verschiedene Anwendungen in Chemie, maschinellem Lernen, Finanzen, Optimierung und so weiter anwenden.
Behalte außerdem im Hinterkopf, dass die Hardware, die du verwenden wirst, eine spezifische Topologie hat. Einige qubits sind nicht verbunden,
andere schon, und letztendlich musst du dein Problem auf einen circuit mappen, der das abbildet. IBM-Quantum-Prozessoren
verwenden eine sogenannte Heavy-Hex-Topologie, die im Wesentlichen qubit-Verbindungen in einem hexagonalen Gitter entspricht,
auf das wir später im Kurs noch näher eingehen werden. Im Moment ist das Wichtigste, woran du denken musst: Diese Phase erfordert
Übung. Du musst nicht nur dein Problem gut verstehen, sondern auch die Quantum-Hardware-
Fähigkeiten, und wir werden später ein konkretes Beispiel und einen Anwendungsfall durchgehen, um zu sehen, wie diese am besten
ausbalanciert werden können. Sprechen wir nun darüber, wie man einen circuit für die ausgewählte Hardware optimiert. Das übergeordnete Ziel des
Optimierungsschritts ist es, alle virtuellen qubits aus unserem circuit auf tatsächliche reale qubits irgendwo auf der
Topologie des Prozessors abzubilden. Das Ziel ist es, Fehler so weit wie möglich zu reduzieren. Dazu müssen wir zunächst unseren circuit effizient
routen und layouten. Das Erste, woran du denken musst: Nicht alle qubits sind verbunden.
Wie ich bereits gesagt habe, sind einige tatsächlich weit voneinander entfernt auf dem Chip, sodass wir Langstrecken-
interaktionen so weit wie möglich reduzieren oder vermeiden müssen. Du kannst eine Folge von Swap-gates zwischen benachbarten qubits anwenden, um qubit-
Informationen zu verschieben, aber Swap-gates sind kostspielig und fehleranfällig, sodass es möglicherweise bessere Vorgehensweisen gibt. Das nächste: Layout
und Routing sind iterative Prozesse, die einem virtuellen qubit in deinem circuit ein physisches qubit auf der
Hardware zuweisen. Du kannst das von Hand tun, aber es gibt auch Tools in Qiskit, die Empfehlungen für das physische
qubit-Layout auf Basis von ungefähren Fehlerraten geben können. Als nächstes können wir Sequenzen von Einqubit-gates, die auf dasselbe qubit wirken,
zu einzelnen gates zusammenfassen, und wir können manchmal auch unnötige gates oder gate-Kombinationen loswerden. Zum Beispiel
können manche gate-Kombinationen auf einfachere Kombinationen reduziert werden, und manchmal entsprechen gate-Kombinationen sogar
einfach einem Identitätsoperator, sodass wir sie schlicht eliminieren können. Das kannst du automatisch mit dem
Qiskit transpiler erledigen, oder du kannst es manuell gate für gate tun, wenn du einen guten Grund dafür hast und mehr
Kontrolle möchtest. Sobald wir das circuit-Layout, Routing und die gate-Anzahl verbessert haben – entweder von Hand oder mit dem Qiskit transpiler –
möchten wir unseren circuit in der Regel visualisieren, um sicherzustellen, dass das Timing aller gates Sinn ergibt. Es gibt ein Argument, das du im transpiler setzen kannst, um
die Zeitachse deines circuit zu visualisieren und sicherzustellen, dass alles so ausgerichtet ist, wie du es erwartest. Sprechen wir nun über Fehler-
unterdrückung. Fehlerunterdrückung bezieht sich auf verschiedene Techniken, die einen circuit während der Kompilierung transformieren, um Fehler zu minimieren.
Sie unterscheidet sich von der Fehlerminderung, die stattfindet, nachdem der circuit bereits ausgeführt wurde – dazu kommen wir gleich. Die zwei häufigsten Formen der
Fehlerunterdrückung, die wir nutzen, sind Dynamical Decoupling und Pauli Twirling. Es wird hier einige
technische Details geben, aber du kannst jederzeit hierauf zurückgreifen. Also: Das erste, Dynamical Decoupling, wird verwendet, um
einen Teil des das qubit beeinflussenden Rauschens effektiv aufzuheben, indem eine Reihe von gates angewendet wird, die zusammen der
Identitätsoperation entsprechen – wie XX-Sequenzen – und deren Nettoeffekt darin besteht, die das qubit beeinflussenden Rauschkanäle näherungsweise aufzuheben.
Pauli Twirling ist eine Methode, bei der zufällige gates eingefügt werden, um das durchschnittliche Rauschen zu vereinfachen. Die Zufälligkeit hilft dabei,
dass sich die Auswirkungen verschiedener Fehler nicht so schnell aufschaukeln, und macht das Rauschen außerdem leichter charakterisierbar.
Diese Methode bildet auch die Grundlage einer Fehlerminderungstechnik, auf die wir später noch eingehen werden.
Es gibt hier viele Informationen, und mach dir keine Sorgen, wenn nicht alles sofort hängen bleibt. Glücklicherweise kann vieles davon automatisch mit dem Qiskit
transpiler erledigt werden. Transpilierung kann zwar knifflig sein, aber Transpilierung ist ein so entscheidender Schritt, um Utility im großen Maßstab zu erreichen,
dass sie viel Ausprobieren erfordert, um gemeistert zu werden und die besten Ergebnisse zu erzielen. Jetzt möchte ich kurz einen
Exkurs machen, um den Qiskit transpiler und seine Fähigkeiten etwas genauer zu besprechen. Ich mache das auf einem sehr hohen Level, und wir werden später auf die Details eingehen und
einige Beispiele sehen. Im Allgemeinen ist Transpilierung der Prozess, einen gegebenen Eingabe-circuit so umzuschreiben, dass er zur
Topologie und dem spezifischen Quantengerät passt, und den circuit für die Ausführung und die Robustheit gegenüber Rauschen zu optimieren. Außerdem
schreibt es einen gegebenen circuit in die Basis-gates des ausgewählten spezifischen Quantenprozessors um. Qiskit hat vier
integrierte transpiler-Pipelines, und falls du noch nicht mit der Optimierung von Quantum circuit vertraut bist, empfehle ich auf jeden Fall, eine davon zu verwenden
Standardmäßig umfasst der transpiler in den integrierten Pipelines diese sechs Schritte: Initialisierung,
Layout, Routing, Übersetzung, Optimierung und Scheduling. Initialisierung bezieht sich dabei auf
jeden anfänglichen Durchlauf, der erforderlich ist, bevor wir mit der Einbettung des circuit auf das backend beginnen. Dies umfasst typischerweise
das Entfalten benutzerdefinierter Anweisungen und das Umwandeln des circuit in Einzel- und Zwei-qubit-Gates. Die Layout-Stufe wendet
ein Layout an, das die virtuellen qubits im circuit den physischen qubits auf einem backend zuordnet. Das Routing läuft nach der Anwendung eines Layouts
und fügt gates wie Swap-gates in den ursprünglichen circuit ein, um ihn mit der Konnektivität des
backend kompatibel zu machen. Die vierte Stufe ist die Übersetzung. In dieser Stufe werden die gates im circuit in den
Basissatz des Ziel-backend übersetzt. Als Nächstes kommt die Optimierung. Diese Stufe führt die wichtigste Optimierungs-
schleife wiederholt aus, bis eine Bedingung erfüllt ist, z. B. das Erreichen einer bestimmten Zieltiefe. Wir haben vier verschiedene Optimierungs-
stufen, aus denen wir wählen können. Zuletzt kommt das Scheduling. Diese Stufe ist für alle hardwarebewussten Scheduling-Durchläufe gedacht. Auf hohem Niveau
kann Scheduling als das Einfügen von Verzögerungen in den circuit betrachtet werden, um etwaige Leerlaufzeiten auf den qubits
zwischen der Ausführung von Anweisungen zu berücksichtigen. Wie gesagt gibt es vier Optimierungsstufen von 0 bis 3, wobei
höhere Optimierungsstufen mehr Zeit und Rechenaufwand benötigen, du aber möglicherweise einen besseren circuit erhältst.
Optimierungsstufe 0 ist für Gerätcharakterisierungsexperimente gedacht und ordnet den Eingabe-circuit daher nur den
Einschränkungen des Ziel-backend zu. Sie führt keine Optimierung durch. Optimierungsstufe 3
investiert den größten Aufwand in die Optimierung des circuit. Da jedoch viele der Optimierungstechniken im
transpiler auf Heuristiken basieren, führt mehr Rechenaufwand nicht immer zu einer Verbesserung
der Qualität des Ausgabe-circuit. Wenn dich das weiter interessiert, schau dir bitte die transpiler-Seiten in der Qiskit-
Dokumentation an, die unten verlinkt ist. Jetzt sind wir bereit, die eigentliche Ausführung eines Quantum circuit zu besprechen.
Die Qiskit Runtime Primitives bieten eine Schnittstelle zur IBM Quantum-Hardware und abstrahieren dabei auch die Fehler-
unterdrückung und -minderung vom Benutzer. Das Sampler Primitive gibt die Quasi-Wahrscheinlichkeitsverteilung oder Zählungen zurück,
die die Wahrscheinlichkeit der Messung bestimmter Bit-Zeichenketten aus Nullen und Einsen darstellen. Das Estimator Primitive gibt Erwartungs-
werte von Observablen zurück, die physikalischen Größen entsprechen. Ein bisschen detaillierter: Der Sampler führt den circuit
mehrmals auf einem Quantengerät aus, führt bei jedem Durchlauf Messungen durch und konstruiert die Wahrscheinlichkeits-
verteilung aus dem Wiederherstellen dieser Bit-Zeichenketten. Je mehr Durchläufe oder Shots er durchführt, desto genauer sind die Ergebnisse,
aber das erfordert mehr Zeit und die benötigten Quantenressourcen. Konkret berechnet er die
Wahrscheinlichkeit, jeden möglichen Standardbasiszustand zu erhalten, indem er den vom circuit vorbereiteten Zustand misst. Qiskits
Estimator verwendet einen komplexen algebraischen Prozess, um den Erwartungswert auf einem echten Quantengerät zu schätzen, indem er
die Observable in eine Kombination anderer Observablen zerlegt, die bekannte Eigenbasen haben, und unter
der Haube der Primitives laufen die sogenannten Fehlerminderungstechniken. Fehlerminderung ist ein Oberbegriff für all das, und es
bezieht sich im Grunde auf die Techniken, die es uns ermöglichen, circuit-Fehler zu reduzieren, indem das Geräterauschen zum Zeitpunkt der
Ausführung modelliert wird. Typischerweise führt dies zu Quanten-Vorverarbeitungsaufwand im Zusammenhang mit dem Modelltraining und klassischem
Nachverarbeitungsaufwand zur Fehlerminderung in den Rohergebnissen mithilfe eines generierten Modells. Im Austausch für diesen
Aufwand sind wir in der Lage, wesentlich genauere Ergebnisse zu erzielen. Es gibt mehrere Techniken, die wir für die
Fehlerminderung implementieren können, und wir werden drei davon genauer besprechen. Beachte jedoch, dass dies ein Bereich
aktiver Forschung ist, sodass wahrscheinlich neue Techniken erfunden werden und ältere weiter verbessert werden. Der
Resilienzlevel erhöht die Kosten, d. h. die Zeit, die für die Ausführung deines Jobs benötigt wird. Wir haben bereits gesagt, dass bei
Resilienzlevel 0 der transpiler deinen circuit nicht wirklich verändert, aber ab Resilienzlevel 1 wird eine Methode namens Twirled
Readout Error Extinction eingeführt, oder kurz T-Rex. Twirled Readout Error Extinction verwendet Pauli-Twirling, um
Rauschen zu mindern, was wir bereits kurz angesprochen haben. Es ist eine sehr allgemeine und effektive Technik, die
intuitiv gesprochen das Rauschen weniger unregelmäßig und leichter handhabbar macht. Ab Resilienzlevel 2 wird
Zero Noise Extrapolation, kurz ZNE, eingeführt. Dies ist eine beliebte Technik, mit der wir in letzter Zeit viele
Erfolge erzielt haben. Die Idee hinter ZNE mag etwas überraschend sein: Wir fügen tatsächlich zusätzliches
Rauschen zu dem bereits vorhandenen hinzu, aber dadurch können wir in die entgegengesetzte Richtung extrapolieren, um
vorherzusagen, wie die Ergebnisse bei weniger Rauschen aussehen würden. Dies kann auf verschiedene spezifische Weisen geschehen. Beispielsweise können wir
die gates verlängern, um sie anfälliger für Fehler zu machen, oder wir können mehr gates ausführen, die letztendlich
in einer Identitätsoperation resultieren, sodass der circuit funktionell nicht verändert wird, wir aber absichtlich mehr
Rauschen sampeln. Du musst das jedoch für jeden circuit und jeden Erwartungswert tun, den du verfolgen möchtest, sodass
du siehst, wie teuer es in Bezug auf die benötigte Zeit werden kann. Eine spezifische Art von ZNE heißt
Probabilistic Error Amplification, kurz PEA. Sobald wir ein Rauschmodell für ein gate erlernt haben, funktioniert PEA, indem es
Fehler aus diesem Rauschmodell sampelt und sie absichtlich in den circuit injiziert. Wie ich erwähnt habe, werden viele neue
Techniken weiterhin entwickelt und werden hoffentlich implementiert, wenn wir mehr und mehr davon in der Praxis sehen. Es gibt nur eine letzte Form der
Fehlerminderung, die ich besprechen möchte: die probabilistische Fehlerauslöschung. Anstatt auf dem dritten Resilienzlevel zu liegen,
ist PEC eine spezielle Fähigkeit, die du in Qiskit manuell aktivieren musst, weil die benötigten Rechenressourcen
im Vergleich zu den anderen besprochenen Fehlerminderungstechniken schlecht skalieren. Du
beginnst damit, das Rauschen zu verstehen, das deinen circuit beeinflusst, indem du Rauschen-Lern- oder Rauschcharakterisierungsläufe
für jede eindeutige Schicht von Zwei-qubit-gates in deinem circuit ausführst. Diese Ergebnisse ermöglichen es dir, das Rauschen
in Form von Pauli-Operatoren zu beschreiben. Sobald du diese Rauschterme kennst, kannst du deine circuits so modifizieren,
dass sie effektiv die entgegengesetzten PECs eingebaut haben, um diese Rauschkanäle aufzuheben. In gewisser Weise ähnelt dieser Prozess
dem von Geräuschisolierenden Kopfhörern. Allerdings ist diese Methode zur Rauschaufhebung sehr kostspielig, da die Laufzeit mit der Anzahl der gates
exponentiell schnell wächst. Für einen sehr großen circuit ist es daher möglicherweise nicht die beste Wahl. Wir haben
jetzt die letzte Stufe erreicht: die Nachverarbeitung. Wenn du gute Arbeit geleistet und geeignete Fehler-
minderungstechniken eingesetzt hast, könnte sich dein Endergebnis verschieben, wie in dieser Abbildung hier. Eine nicht geminderte Verteilung,
in Lila dargestellt, liegt weit vom wahren Erwartungswert entfernt, der hier durch diese Linie dargestellt ist. Sobald wir jedoch unsere Fehler-
minderung anwenden, erhalten wir eine geminderte Verteilung, die hier in Blau dargestellt ist und ihren Höhepunkt viel näher am wahren Wert hat. Nun,
das hat alles seinen Preis, und hier können wir sehen, dass die Varianz oder die Breite der Verteilung zunimmt, was
im Allgemeinen nicht das ist, was du möchtest, aber alles hat seinen Preis. Zum Glück können wir dem entgegenwirken, indem wir mehr
Shots ausführen, wodurch die Verteilung auf ein akzeptables Maß an Unsicherheit zurückschrumpft. Das war es also in etwa für diese
Lektion. Für das nächste Mal werden wir all diese Schritte zusammenfügen und ein Beispiel aus einem
echten Anwendungsbereich durcharbeiten. Es gibt ein paar Dinge, die ich bis dahin empfehlen kann. Falls du es noch nicht getan hast,
lade Qiskit 1.0 herunter und richte es ein. Du kannst auch die zugehörige Lektion für dieses Kapitel und
die vorherige Episode auf der IBM Quantum Learning-Plattform ansehen, und schließlich, wenn du mehr Interesse daran hast, tiefer einzutauchen und
mehr über Fehlerminderungstechniken zu erfahren, schau dir eine der zahlreichen Quellen an, die ich unten verlinkt habe. Bis dahin sehen wir uns beim nächsten Mal!
[Musik]